[Musik]
und willkommen
ich weiß nicht ob chinesen oder inder
sind aber auf jeden fall sagen wird
immer an der macht
wenn ein indisches rezept kommt denn ihr
wollt immer indische rezepte und das
freut mich weil ich liebe die indische
küche und wenn haben sondern ich mal
draußen essen im restaurant dann ist es
immer indischen dann können wir uns dann
immer indische küche weil das dann immer
so vielfältig ist jedenfalls gibt es
heute butter chicken eine delikatesse
ich liebe das ist richtig richtig lecker
butter chicken und mango schicken sie
meine zwei lieblingsgerichte vom inder
und ich zeige euch hier mal die zutaten
sind auch relativ überschaubar wir
beginnen hier mit cashewkerne dann haben
wir hier knoblauch und ingwer salz chili
etwas scharfes chili hier habe ich ihr
paprika flocken die sind nicht schafft
dann natürlich hähnchenbrust öl da habe
ich einfach neutrales öl genommen und
hier geht es jetzt eigentlich weiter mit
der soße
das sind einmal tomaten habe ich schon
geviertelt sie wollen dann könnte rote
oder auch ganz normale gelbe nehmen hier
haben wir noch salz und zucker
lorbeerblätter paprikapulver garam
masala das gibt es auch fertig zu kaufen
galamaz pfeffer sahne essig butter und
wasser und das war's schon es klingt
viel im ersten moment aber eigentlich
hat man ja fast alles da was ich
vielleicht kaufen müsste ist das gras
aber dann hat das auch einmal darum kurz
immer wieder genau so genau
dann wird somit keine
geschmacksexplosion und wir starten
jetzt zuallererst mit unserem fleisch
dafür räume ich jetzt die sachen weg kam
machten cut und dann sehen wir uns
gleich wieder die hähnchenbrust habe ich
hier schon gewaschen getrocknet und in
mundgerechte stücke geschnitten wobei
mutter schicken mag ich dass wir die
stücke da so ein bisschen dicker sind
als könnte ja beliebig entscheiden
jetzt gibt dir etwas öl dazu das ist
neutrales öl und wir marinieren das
ganze jetzt natürlich mit salz dann habe
ich hier
paprika flocken die sind jetzt
allerdings nicht scharf ich habe hier
zusätzlich noch etwas chili
wir können ja so ein bisschen variieren
bei ich weiß nicht jeder mag halt eine
andere schärfe haben sie und ich mögen
es nicht so scharf und da reibe ich
jetzt noch knoblauch und ingwer rein
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt alle zutaten für die
marinade zum fleisch geben als wir das
einmal gut umgerührt am besten mit einem
touch aber was ist das für ein tolles
euro gibson zu kaufen
den gibts bei uns im shop und der ist
einfach wunderschön ich bin ja muss man
die wand hängen da hatten wir noch nicht
ein parteitag
aber wenn wir nicht wunderschön und das
ist mein baby
so und jetzt höre ich das richtig gut um
und dann müsst ihr das ziehen lassen
also ich bin ganz ehrlich ist es immer
leckere wenn ihr das ein paar stunden
ziehen lassen wenn ihr so zwei drei
stunden zeit habt dann macht das gerne
auch am vortag wenn ihr keine zeit hat
dann reichen auch 20 minuten das mache
ich heute auch damit das video auch
längst fertig wird und wir essen können
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt hier eine beschichtete
pfanne da habe ich schon ein neutrales
öl rhein gegeben das schön erhitzen
lassen und jetzt werden unsere
fleischtöpfe darin angebraten
macht euch keine sorgen also bereitet
sie einfach nur von außen richtig schön
an und wenn die nicht durch sind ist das
kein problem ich habe jetzt dicke stücke
es ist kein problem weil wir das gleich
nochmal jahren werden in den saft also
in der soße quasi
[Musik]
kleiner tipp von hier brach das gern in
zwei phasen an damit die stücke einfach
nicht übereinander liegen und jedes
stück schön geklappt hat
[Musik]
das fleisch ist jetzt vorab fertig das
gebe ich jetzt zuallererst mal an die
seite und wir kümmern uns jetzt um die
leckere soße
ich habe jetzt hier schon die hier
zwiebeln vorbereitet da müsste jetzt
auch nicht besonders darauf achten wie
feindlich schneidet denn gleich wird
alles einmal püriert ihr habt jetzt auch
noch reste im topf und da gebe ich jetzt
auch noch ein bisschen öl dazu das habe
ich jetzt schon gemacht und dann ganz
einfach die zwiebeln darin dünstet man
gibt sich auch schon die tomaten dazu
[Musik]
liebe
ich habe jetzt auch für die cashewkerne
mit dazu gegeben und diesen auch ganz
ganz wichtig für die seligkeit die
konsistenz und guter trick ist für mich
eine ganz training eine ganz feine und
das machen eben die cashewkerne unter
anderem jetzt völlig das ganze auch mit
ganz normalem leitungswasser dass das
noch einmal aufkochen damit auch schön
hitze da ist und dann machen wir den
deckel drauf und lassen das 15 minuten
lang köchin
ich glaube übrigens jetzt auch schon die
gewürze mit dazu kann das nämlich
richtig schön köcheln mit den gewürzen
und falls ihr euch jetzt fragt warum ich
zucker reinmache bei tomaten passen also
passt zucker einfach wunderbar und ich
finde darauf solltet ihr auch nicht
verzichten er den pfeffer und die
lorbeerblätter die gebe ich gleich erst
mit dazu das hat gleich einen besonderen
grund das verrate ich aber gleich erst
jetzt fängt das langsam an zu köcheln
und dann deckel drauf und 15 minuten
lang köcheln lassen
die 15 minuten sind um und jetzt ist
alles wunderbar weich die tomaten
zwiebeln insbesondere aber hier die
tasche kerne und deshalb habe ich den
herd ausgeschaltet und püriert das jetzt
einmal in einer pfanne
ihr könnt natürlich auch erstmal
umfüllen aber ich mache das direkt hier
denn gleich wird das noch passiert das
kann natürlich auch schon mal zeigen
gleich passiere ich das ganze noch mal
damit die kerne der tomaten und die haut
einfach entfernt wird und wie das gleich
richtig schön sämig weich haben
[Musik]
jetzt kommt die passierte soße einmal
zurück in den topf dann könnt ihr dann
wieder ein schalten den herd auf die
mittlere stufe diesmal und er gibt ein
ganz einfacher fleisch zurück in die
soße und lass es dann nochmal so circa
zehn bis zwölf minuten garen dass es
auch wirklich komplett durch gegarten
ist auch wirklich hier
der saft der hier ausgetreten ist auch
mit dazu
und an der stelle gebe ich jetzt auch
die lorbeerblätter mit dazu weil jetzt
kann ich sie gleich ganz einfach raus
fischen jetzt ist ja schon alles schön
püriert und die butter sahne gebe ich
erst ganz zum schluss mit dazu und es
kommt auch jetzt schon mit rein wenn ihr
auf essig verzichten möchte
warum auch immer weil er den geschmack
nicht mögt es gibt aber noch mal eine
schöne säure dann könnt ihr auch so ein
spritzer limettensaft das stelle ich mir
auch sehr lecker vor
und jetzt ist unser butter chicken
fertig und das riecht so köstlich nur
noch die lorbeerblätter entfernen
eventuell nach pfeffern und nachsalzen
wobei pfeffer habt ihr auch schon im
gerda masala drin also immer schön
vorsichtig sein und ich sehe hier dazu
jetzt reiß reis passt eigentlich immer
ganz gut dazu oder er macht zum beispiel
selbst gebacken des indisches namen brot
also dann hast du eigentlich brot aber
ich wollte euch noch fragen wenn ihr
euch weitere indische rezepte von
gewünscht schreibt sie mir doch gerne in
die kommentare dann so sorge was hab ich
ja also selbst gebaut müssen namen grund
ich wüsste auch nicht was leckeres
gekauftes namen brot gibt selbst gemacht
ist sowieso immer viel weiß was ich
mache und dass es auf jeden fall schon
mal ein rezept auf unserer liste und die
liste darf ruhig langsam leser diese
liebe indische rezepte und ich hoffe
dass ihr dieses auch nach macht er
spielt einfach köstlich
ich glaube also ich mache immer gerne
noch angaben zur person zeigt also das
ist jetzt für fünf personen aber ich
glaube wir zwei essen jetzt heute und
morgen davon auf jeden fall
und genau die genauen mengenangaben
stehen wie immer hier unten in der
infobox also screenshot machen einkaufen
gehen und nachmachen und im besten falle
gibt in diesem video ein dörfchen nach
oben wenn es euch gefallen hat natürlich
ein kostenloses abo dann verpasst ja
auch nichts mehr
und dann sehen wir uns beim nächsten mal
auf die skatingski verlieben
[Musik]